Italy famous for its luxury Brands is
facing a major problem a shortage of
Artisans the very skilled workers whose
expertise make these products in the
town of thermo Italy luxury brand Fendi
thinks it's found a solution training
school students
[Music]
from master painters of the Renaissance
to leather makers in Tuscany Italy is
renowned for its Master Craftsmen so
when Serge Brunswick came to Rome to
become fendi's new chief executive in
2018 he was surprised to find there was
a major issue with the workforce a
shortage of Artisans if we want to do
more objects we need more people for
Generation goals where is the next
Generation lack of Artisans isn't just
an Italian issue from a deaf of
blacksmith in Australia to much of
Europe's luxury sector countries are
struggling to train and retain
sufficient numbers of people in key
Industries but in Italy the problem is
particularly acute according to luxury
trade group Ultra gamma there are about
240 000 students enrolled in
professional schools in France almost
900 000 in Germany and only about 17 000
in Italy and yet Italy's current youth
unemployment rate stands at 24 this is
where Brunswick had an idea as a
foreigner you ask a few questions like
is there a technical Apprentice trip in
is there does it exist and the fact it
hardly exists this is firmo a center of
Italian shoemaking that started as far
back as the 15th century it is here that
Fendi built a new Factory and started
recruiting young people onto their
production lines run by altagama in
collaboration with Italy's education
Ministry where young people in the last
two years of trade school can take
internships with companies like Fendi
Bulgari and Gucci the initial response
despite initial skepticism the
apprenticeship scheme is starting to
change attitudes to factory
Works see
entry-level positions in the sector can
start at around 1 000 to 1 200 Euros net
per month According to altercamer which
isn't a lot but is comparable to
starting salaries in many office jobs in
Italy so is Fendi paying students enough
I don't think it's an issue I mean again
if they are young in their first job
the first salary that you will get
typically the Fendi and the residents of
firmo though the opportunities in
shoemaking are changing perceptions and
boosting business
how do you make you know this city with
a future if you don't create local jobs
there which could be done by the local
people in Italian
[Music]
foreign
[Music]